THE, LOOK AT HIS HEAD, NEAR THE
RIM LEVEL.
NICE ACTING JOB THERE BY
McLEMORE.
>> Brian: SOME FUDGERY THERE
FROM McLEMORE.
IT WORKED.
>> Reggie: YES.
>> Brian: McLEMORE AND BROWN,
AND THEY ARE TRYING TO GET
SPACED OUT A LITTLE BIT THERE
FOR THE BLAZERS AND THE
THREE-POINTER IS ON THE WAY FROM
BRANDON WILLIAMS, AND HIS FIRST
MADE THREE OF HIS CAREER.
THE UNDRAFTED ROOKIE OUT OF
ARIZONA.
I DON'T THINK THAT HE IS A
THREAT TO CATCH CURRY, BUT HE IS
ON THE WAY.
>> Reggie: WELL, HE ONLY HAS
3,083 TO GO.
HE IS RIGHT ON HIS TAIL
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Brian: ARE WE KEEPING A
MARKER ON THIS?
>> Reggie: YES, HE IS THERE.
>> Brian: 3,084 TO 1.
BUT YOU CAN'T GET TO 3,084
UNLESS YOU HAVE ONE.
THAT HAS TO BE A GREAT FEELING
FOR HIM, AND BRANDON WILLIAMS
WITH A CHANCE ON THE 10-DAY
CONTRACT AND LOST THE HANDLE TO
TURN IT OVER.
AND CURRY PUSHING IT, AND
THOMPSON IN THE C